I love Christmas music I love Christmas
I have a terrible memory there is just
one thing I need and I need something
present just for you to be my man I
think that's it make my wish come true
all I want for Christmas is you yep but
I knew that one it's in love actually so
that's why I remember Good King
Wenceslas looked out the feast of
Stephen Stephen Stephen Christmas they
had husks of corn and Merry Christmas -
Stephen here's a brand-new pair of pants
jingle bell jingle bell oh [ __ ]
jingle bell lime bananas bananas that's
not it something and bump - dancing with
horse is now Jingle Bell Rock is it on
Mean Girls right
twelve twelve twelve eleven gum drops
dropping ten Lords a-leaping nine uses
eight maids a-milking seven swans
a-swimming six big laying five
for mockingbirds me I don't want to - to
- oh [ __ ] and a part it's a partridge in
a pear tree nailed it
you're a mean one mr. Grinch even suit
you're as cuddly as or something
the cactus as ah I should know this
ah you're a tiny spotted leopard and you
do not give a [ __ ] you're a - Dekker -
double-decker cheese for everything a
salami sandwich he says something like
that I can do most of these verses
actually that's my takeaways I feel like
I know all these at heart but my mouth
doesn't remember what my heart does hey
doesn't matter if you don't know the
words just sing your heart out happy
holidays merry mother-effing Chris